ja ich will heiraten in der schweiz
präsentiert von amag von vier paaren
handeln diese geschichten von menschen
die uns von dem augenblick erzählen als
sich ihre herzen gefunden haben wie ihr
alltag plötzlich einen hauch von magie
erhielt und wieder raus träume und
hoffnungen entstanden aber auch
sehnsucht und schmerz sie alle daten
eines der größten abenteuer des lebens
sie heiraten
[Musik]
es ist selten dass andrea buch ecke und
ihr zukünftiger ehemann uhr liberté zeit
finden um hier im toggenburg am waldrand
über die eigenen wiesen zu spazieren und
auch an dies im freien tag gibt es einen
guten grund für ihren kleinen ausflug
ist ihr herz hängt sich gefunden
80 hatte unter dem jetzt ausschnitte und
doch mit sorge wurde vor dem schnitzel
und wir dass der neue könig der asche
den wiesen zu machen
die mitarbeiterin der universität st
gallen und einen wert auslasten im
toggenburg sind eines von über 40.000
paaren die in diesem jahr in der schweiz
heiraten gesprochen habe ich doch der
nachforderungen brüder und so weit da
fangen dann über danach boxen problem
kommt der honig aber doch heinz büse
herzogtum lauenburg us-bericht da hat
sich den erst zwei jahre später regel
nicht oder falsch ist und jetzt ist es
soweit wir das so machen und uns noch
zwei schritte und da ich so superschnell
läutet das durchschnittsalter das war
dauer auch gesät das dauert ja noch
richtig noch nicht den herrschersitz
unisono zur vorzeichnen bleistift eines
feststellen sagt verrät milliarden nur
ein versuch und schmeckt muss primär
darum ist es gut wenn noch bis nach dem
us recht da bin ich mir anders klingt
vor ihm und darum dass wesentlich
weniger vorstellungen vom leben und die
gleiche erwartungen aus liebe oder hat
aber mehr gerne weiter
und darum haben wir eine relativ schnell
klar dass das passiert ist
in oftringen zwischen bahngleis und
hauptstraße wohnen zwei die sich an der
lärmigen wohnlage nicht stören
manuela egger und christian hilfiger
sind beide gehörlos
eines der aufregendsten erlebnisse war
als manuela vor gut einem jahr einen
ausflug machte und nicht wusste wohin
die reise geht
christians bruder uli begleitete sie und
filmte dabei ankommen
berger bei den wegen die stücke und sie
mal von drehen
mein bruder christian hatte das alles
eingefädelt und nur vorgegeben er müsse
arbeiten
doch das wusste manuela nicht als sie
ihn radon in den hellen der air zermatt
stieg
ich bin noch nie mit jakob decke bogen
patrick ist noch dass gott verbindet
bald da du nur was sie in diesem
augenblick nicht wusste war was es mit
diesem verbunden flughelfer auf sich
hatte
[Musik]
der pilot gesehen
es war ebenfalls vor einem jahr als sich
uli ein herz fasste sinopec das bringt
nur angegangen nationalpark und den ich
denk da passt wunderbar denn haben sie
denkt der stadt darunter das ist so noch
nie
zum zweiten mal waren zeigt ist und wie
es halt etwas ganz leicht auch noch am
nächsten halt schön ruft gar überhaupt
ist der weg ganz schön stieg sie und
denkt muss es auch doch irgendwie daheim
machen und daher nicht den haben wir gar
keine kapazitäten verlagert es ist
vielleicht zu lang dennoch nicht fragen
sie den zug sein
[Gelächter]
heute war ich zum ersten mal ist das
genial wo sie doch noch um hilfe
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
yahoo
der helle mit manuela und dem als
flughelfer getankten christian hilfiger
näherte sich am 2 juni 2012 dem radar
auf dem petersplatz auf über 3000 meter
über meer gibt sich christian zu
erkennen
[Musik]
am zugersee lieben aldiana novakovic und
redner petkovic seit fünf jahren sind
sie ein paar
in diesem saal des zuger casinos werden
der immobilienfachmann und die
kaufmännische angestellte demnächst
hochzeit feiern
das vorstellen
es ist einfach mega
ja aber es wird jedes mal um habe ich
würde am liebsten im jahr zu buche als
recht gemacht
aldiana und treten erwarten über 100
gäste mehr als die hälfte stand wie das
brautpaar ursprünglich aus serbien ein
paar verwandte werden sogar direkt aus
belgrad anreisen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das kann man noch so auf dem flachdach
über das wetter zu wünschen übrig das
soll sich bis zur hochzeit ändern damit
wie vor genau einem jahr hier auf der
terrasse die sonne scheint wirklich
symbolisch für die logistik für das
projekt liefern nicht die hand halte ich
gemerkt so nach vier jahren bezieht dass
sie so drückt also drückt aber man hat
so ganz diskret aber das ist gut so und
wir haben schon immer gesagt wenn man
mal hier oder da jetzt ausgelotet und
den hj kontaktaufnahme hand das super
vorbereitet alles für text versteckt die
die kolleginnen involviert die hand mit
machte bis zum nächsten stopp wieder und
wenn ja auf den ball kommen auf sie
gewartet
es passiert ganz sehr ruhig und sehr
stehen und kann informiert ich bin sehr
überrascht wie viele nehmen das ist
einfach die überraschung ich einfach
gerne mit dem wir die ganz familie hätte
ich sehr
die liebe kennt auch jene versteckten
winkel die sonst kaum mehr jemand
besucht so ein ort ist der ochsen
inzwischen ruht die hier lebt christian
reich das ist so komisch mit dem
verliebtsein ältere und da tut man sich
nicht einfach verlegen wie ihr ganz
besonders dass ich aus dem buch und
staune ich hatte nicht erklären und sie
hat mit ihrem kleid aber darum dass das
passiert ist mit der hand einfach denn
hand möglich war kam er hand an andere
getroffen und guido hannich einfach
jeden tag die zähne an mit denen kontakt
jeden tag telefonieren im indischen teil
ist jetzt minimum aber meistens toni
telefonieren wir wollen das thema garten
oder das haus in dem christian reich
lebt könnte eine metapher für sein leben
sein denn dieses ist schon so manches
mal aus den fugen geraten
im baufälligen ochsen ist er sein bester
gast
immerhin hat er zeit spanisch zu lernen
denn seine herzensdame liegt in der
dominikanischen republik
er selber aus dem keller inmitten von
allerlei schachteln und ramsch schläft
er auf einer matratze
ja
das ist mist aber ich werde ja wohl kaum
ja wir haben echt an allen hanna frische
luft
der heutige meter und dann bin ich noch
nicht kann wie der vag machen
durch die normale stunde blicke gefangen
da mitzumachen
also man in der folge dass leute sagen
er lebe in einem armseligen doch das
stört die nicht ja heute wohnen kaum
bewegt und viel lieber investiert das
sein geld in die fernbeziehung mit
bieren weniger doch bmw nieder ist in
der schweiz nicht willkommen ich hab
mich einfach ich wäre dankbar in zug im
casino wollen aldiana und treten heute
ihr hochzeitsmenü testen
[Musik]
gibt es vielleicht aldiana uns reden
sind in der schweiz aufgewachsen und
haben den schweizer pass ihre hochzeit
wollen sie jedoch ganz in serbischer
tradition feiern
also mir hat einfach nur gruppe vorliegt
wo das ist ein spezielles instrument
ganz los und das ist eigentlich das
highlight wir mehr handwerk stellt dass
das sehr gut auch und blond ist dies
grundsätzlich immer aber erstes bekommen
soll
und das war nicht ein andré winter will
das wird eine halbe stunde dadurch so
wirkliches highlight vor dem fest wo
vermutlich die meisten mitmachen nicht
vor
das tut sie das mit dem zurück wir sind
offen exil messen
ich sage ihnen ich mag das und nicht
sicher nicht wieso 14 das ist das
schönste was also tun sagt ich hasse und
sie noch bleibt genügend zeit bis zum
großen tag der für alle unvergesslich
werden soll
das werden wir zu viel und das ist nicht
viel aber für die süße der sich daher
werde ich wenig aber es wird ein schutz
fehler wenn wir das so viel besser als
dankt und den will man doch dass es
schön wird und zum vergessen gut und ich
zahle gefallen stressige zeit wo sowas
geblieben beim sehr flink das war nicht
so lustig aber das getriebe ja es geht
erhebungen oder zweifel
für fragen über reibungen zweifel fällt
es christian reich nicht an zeit und
muße nur sind seine probleme die ihm ein
idyllisches zusammenleben erschweren
aktenkundig wären wir nie da ist nämlich
bereits die dritte frau die er hals über
kopf in der karibik heiraten will
oder besser bereits geheiratet hat
dummerweise bevor er von der vorgängerin
geschieden war
kein wunder also wie die schweiz die
erneute eheschließung der 77-jährigen
scheinheirat es nicht anerkennen hat
jetzt enthüllt da fängt eigentlich sie
dh ich bin und dass ich da frankel
natürliche hilfe kam rechte hand und
dann ich sehe halt das kreuz mit hoch
und das hat der fc augsburg klopft hatte
parkproblem g aber seit maß ich leite
eine ganz gleich unter hoch der hat sich
nach die integrierte wähle ich brauche
nicht weder lehre hat 90 so staub
kapseln und trug zog und jetzt ich sie
auf dem sozialamt und das volk man
natürlich überhaupt macht dass sie ihren
unterhalt aus alba muss verlieren die
hilfe für und mit meint heidi fischer
und kasami akzeptiere er sicher werden
auch zu kaffee jedem anspruch der
verwaltung betont macht irgendwann
einmal empfehlen und die konnte ich habe
fehler gemacht aber wir haben immer
vorgehabt der immer probiert
diese einigermassen eigenwillige sicht
für recht und unrecht führten christian
reich immer wieder aufs glatteis und
einmal sogar hinter gitter
ich habe drogen machte die
dominikanische ich habe zwei hunde
genommen chemiker ponys im kabarett
schaffte united problem könnte und ich
konnte mal sehr unsicher und mit der
frank hat keine macht und für den
transport tätig das überhaupt aber dann
hat mich halt essen und natürlich
politik hat und dann bin ich im knast
verurteilt bin ich wollte zu 420 meinen
bedingt auf drei jahre
und das haben jetzt die abgabe von sich
weist ihre dummheit macht kann die
schweizer teilnehmer machen
doch das seine vergangenheit jetzt
zählen nur noch die liebe
[Musik]
dem glück von manuela und christian
steht nichts im weg die deutsche und der
schweizer nutzen jede freie minute um
ihr hochzeitsfest vorzubereiten
sie können zum stehen
ein zweiter genick zu brechen
geschickt
die stücke so unterscheidet man die
vorfreude der beiden ist spürbar
viele von manuelas verwandten und noch
mehr freunde werden aus bayern zur
hochzeit anreisen was die hälfte der
gäste ist wie das paar gehörlos auf
ihren idyllischen bauernhof
us-amerikanischen lassen machte ulrich
seiner andrea letztes jahr den
heiratsantrag schöne dass der markt und
das frau früher bin ja ja reform zu
seinem selbstverständnis gehört aber
nicht nur dass der mann den
heiratsantrag macht und schöne gerade
mist tochter und vater etage früheren
gemachten durch dennoch viel schöner
gemacht und nur zeitung so daran ideen
einfach fast siebenfach doppel durch das
viereck ist das ist schön offen gülle
kasten oberstadt dass das achte double
auf und ich haben schönes bildern oder
stroh stopp
jetzt ist vater zimmermann mit
gesteigerten lang jetzt kommt sie jetzt
kommen andere stöckli und mit schlägen
das große highlight sorgen ob es passt
also wird gebastelt alles sei dass sie
gut
oldies braut andrea hat einen nicht
minder wichtigen termin in der stadt st
gallen mit hilfe von zwei freundinnen
die sie heute eine vielleicht
folgenschwere entscheidung treffen wo
bis aber mal eine meerjungfrau stehen
wird auf dem ring ist oder möchte das
ist ja der hammer
also ich glaube zu mir dass der biss ist
schlicht das nicht irgendwie die letzten
monate hat uli berti neben dem
bauernhaus das stöckli für seine eltern
gebaut
fast alles hat der gelernte schreiner
selber gemacht einen monat bevor die
eltern einziehen muss heute die treppe
montiert werden
ja das habe ich jetzt das täglich macht
für uns also für ältere oder und aber
die idee stürmer von ihs alles horses
meist seien dafür die wünsche nach
bringen seite gern besser so dass
möglichst momenten ist es ja das haben
wir auch gemacht aber für später
aufpasste d'andrea nicht wahrscheinlich
wo einige boni zu schnell und einiger
sei daher aber lustig dafür tun dass wir
noch nicht aber man weiß dass ich mein
büro das traumpaar und in trier spielt
haben wir endlich andreas dass sie sich
denn alle hier so betonte nadal und 174
g 2
so also schlief das normale ich war
schon noch richtig schön also macht die
figur ja das ist nicht alles gut aber
vom regen druckstock das leben ist
nächste
noch glauben
[Musik]
ja einfach endlich zu bringen hat und
zudem schon da hätte er den sicher
geglaubten die höchste marke kattus also
bleibe und die ganze strecke hält prof
und dank variabler machen jede frau
stört da die meisten ist die ganze oder
aufstoßen
[Musik]
andrea hat sich entschieden haben und es
ist gleich dem 60
das bis heute vorstellt
und wenn es nicht andreas schönheit ist
die hinaus den socken hauen wird dann
vielleicht der preis des kleides das
noch nicht überlaufen
allerdings sieht man schleppen
kunststoff in rüti im zürcher oberland
wird christian reich von der sehnsucht
nach seiner pnp nidda gequält
vor einem jahr hat er sie in der
dominikanischen republik aufs standesamt
geführt vergeblich das einzige was er
von ihr hat sind sms die er säuberlich
in sein tagebuch schreibt meine liebe
waren du bist nicht du bist mein engel
ich liebe dich
[Musik]
die 47-jährige wären wir wieder den
carmen lebt in einem hübschen haus in
einen besseren viertel der stadtwerke
platte seit sie christian vor bald
sieben jahren kennengelernt hat könnte
sich mehr leisten als die meisten
menschen auf der karibikinsel
über ihren christian spricht sie nur
gutes es ist schwierig auszudrücken was
mir christian bedeutet er ist eine
unglaubliche person mit einem guten
herzen ihrem große gefühle füreinander
es ist ein spezieller menschen mich ja
klar er unterstützt mich schichten ihr
geld
ich arbeite nicht wäre aber familie zwei
söhne und das leben hier ist sehr teuer
baracken wie ein wenig kennt nicht nur
die vergangenheit von christian sie weiß
auch wie er wohnt trotzdem sagt sie sie
wolle ihr haus unter der karibischen
sonne verlassen und so ihm in die
schweiz ziehen in den keller
ich weiß nicht ob das ging im keller ist
es versuchen nicht und wenn es nicht
geht müssen wir eine wohnung
es braucht einfach eine frauen hat damit
alles gut wird
juni das so jeffrey und rosé äußern sich
nicht zu den umzugsplänen sie werden
hier in der dominikanischen republik
bleiben
[Musik]
das ist das besonders wichtig das ist
dass ich mit einem clip das alles jetzt
nach drei wochen die ganzen oder maße b
schon mitmachen
und du bist danke dem funktioniert das
alles rund ums boot meter tief steht
auch das schlachten sieht dabei so dass
am schluss zu
also ich finde dass sie sich zu bewirkt
[Applaus]
manuela und christian haben heute besuch
anita cola die fahrerin welche die
beiden trauen wert ist da wo habt ihr
echt beide kennen herz auch nicht gerade
ferien oder großen silvester top ist
aber das bedeutet du bist wirklich vom
von münchen weg hierher war es nicht
schwierig oder war klar warum gefühl
gefehlt gestellt und heute ist jetzt für
uns drei wichtig genau zu schauen was
möchtet ihr beide was ist für euch an
dieser feier das wichtigste das ist
nicht gut das ist konsequent dass es
durch gezogen
musik direkt direkt aufs ziel habt ihr
euch ein thema für das ganze überlegt
ein bär behörden aber das tier okay es
ist ein bisschen schwierig etwas zu
finden in der bibel zu diesem thema aber
ich bin sicher ich finde
denn mit finde ich gut
dann suche ich ein anfangs oder eingangs
wort zum thema wären was ist anders ich
[Musik]
finde ich finde ich immer einen schönen
satz ihr könnt das ja in zeiten ist das
papier ein gegenbesuch in version 5 0
du hast wirklich so schön gesagt er ist
der richtige mann
und diese überzeugung da ist es ja egal
ist jemand gehörlos hörend blind das ist
so egal
liebe gott liebe egal wo nächste woche
in unserer hochzeit serie christian
hilfiger präsentiert seine braut und der
schwiegermutter seinen hochzeitsanzug
[Musik]
christian reich reist in die
dominikanische republik zu seiner bieren
wir nieder
[Musik]
wir lernen uli bercks 13-jährigen sohn
pascal kennen
zusammen mit andrea begleitet er den
papa an eine viehschau und wir erhalten
einblicke in die serbisch-orthodoxe
tradition wenn sich aldiana und treten
auf ihren schönsten tag vorbereiten
ja ich will heute in einer woche
[Musik]
ja ich will heiraten in der schweiz mit
groupe mutuel versicherungen groupe
mutuel seit 20 jahren für sie da